les cours de récréation là tout à
l'heure mon fils de 9 ans est entré
maman c'était la saint valentin il faut
tous se trouvait une meuf comme il dit
mais bon vu comment tu parles et donc il
y avait toutes les histoires d'amour
aujourd'hui c'était vraiment toute une
affaire ça commence très tôt j'étais
chez le coiffeur il ya quelques jours et
j'entendais un père dire à son office
alors est-ce que tu as une petite copine
son fils de trois ans et on disait avec
le coiffeur mais c'est quand même fou
pourquoi est ce qu'il est - poser de
questions là maintenant il a trois ans
son petit garçon et à l'adolescence au
collège et au lycée il faut savoir une
chose c'est que pour avoir une existence
celle il faut être en couple c'est à
dire qu'avant d'être quelqu'un comme
avril prévient c'est à dire de comment
est-ce qu'on développe aussi sa propre
personnalité avant de se mettre en
couple on se dit que c'est le couple qui
me donne une identité mais le ritz est
très dangereux cette affaire là parce
que nous adultes on rigole bien c'est
trop mignon mon fils à sa petite copine
mafia 110 copains et on trouve ça
adorable et c'est très problématique
parce que si on se met en couple avant
de s'être construit avant d'être
quelqu'un est bien ce couple peut être
dangereux et je pèse mes mots quand je
dis dangereux pourquoi parce que on
pourrait ne plus pouvoir exercer sa
liberté dans ce couple si j'attends de
l'autre qu'il me définit ce qu'il me
donne une raison d'exister c'est à dire
qu'il réponde à ma grande question
existentielle suis-je aimable mais oui
je suis aimable puisque je suis en
couple et je prouve à tout le collège et
tout le lycée comme moi je suis aimable
puisque je suis en couple le jour où mon
petit copain me dis si tu m'aimes fais
moi plaisir un moment une photo de toi
non pas que le col roulé et quoi tu me
fais pas confiance mais quand on s'aime
on se fait confiance et si tu m'aimes tu
dois me faire plaisir alors chantier bat
non ça je vais pas faire des nude comme
on dit ou des vidéos de moi en faisant
des choses sexuelles j'ai pas le faire
et ça veut dire que tu ne m'aimes pas
mais si tu ne m'aimes pas eh bien j'ai
plus de raison d'être avec toi donc
qu'est ce que je risque en tant qu' en
tant que jeune fille de perdre l'amour
de mon petit copain et d'avoir une très
mauvaise réputation
[Musique]
m